3minutes,
I ask the 3minutes how
make 1 demonstration per recurrence,
still call reasoning by recurrence.
The demonstration by recurrence
is 1 property
which consists in showing that a property
is true for all anti-naturals.
It is done in 3 stages.
The 1st one,
is the initialization.
At this point,
you ask that your probabette is real
for the whole 1st natural whole
1 equals 0 or 1 equals 1 depending on the case.
Step 2,
Heredity,
at this stage,
you ask that if your property is true to rank N,
and then it is also at rank N plus 1,
then you make the conclusion.
I make you 1
small illustration to show you what it is.
So let's assume that we are 1 man in front of 1 staircase
and that we want to show him
that this man is able to climb
all the steps of the stairs,
it would be necessary that
this one is able to mount
the very first step of the stairs.
This is the equivalent of initialization.
But is it enough to demonstrate
who can climb the whole stairs?
No,
we should be able to demonstrate
that he is able to pass
a step of the stairs
at 1 other step of the stairs.
This is therefore heredity.
In conclusion,
if yes,
the man is able to pass
from the ground to the 1st step of the stairs
and that it is able to pass
one step of the stairs to 1
another step of the stairs,
then he is able to climb the whole stairs.
This is exactly the principle of the demonstration.
By recurrence,
let's see all this with 1 concrete example,
or the sequence U N defined by U 0 equal to 2,
U N plus 1 equals 1+1 divided by 1 plus U N.
We will together by recurrence that
for any theme
1 inferrogala U 1 inferrogala 2,
the initialization is quite simple to remember,
in this case,
U 0 is equal to 2,
1 is indeed 1 to 2
which is indeed 1 to 2.
The property is true,
Oran is equal to 0.
Let's move on to heredity.
We want to prove here that if the property
is true Oran N,
then it is also,
Oran N plus 1,
I write what I want to achieve,
I would like to have 1,
1 Ferrero equals 1+1,
1 Ferrero equals 2.
Replacing U N plus 1 with its expression,
I have 1 ferea equal to 1+1 divided by 1 plus U N F O
equal to 2.
So my starting point,
this is what I consider admitted.
My goal is to start from 1 ferea equal to U
1 iron equals 2
and result in 1 ferega at U N plus 1,
1 ferea equal to 2.
So to do this,
I add 1 to the expression of U N,
which makes me add 1 on the left and right.
Then I take the opposite of U N plus 1,
I also take the opposite of 2 and the opposite of 3
by taking the opposite of the inverse of 3,
I have 1/2 and 1 third,
except that 1 third becomes smaller than 1/2.
After I do more than 1 on all terms
as I have in the expression of Us 1,
so 1 third plus 1 ferrogala
1+1 divided by U N plus 1,
1 ferrogala 1+1 half.
So I just got um plus 1,
I just framed U N plus 1
so what makes me 4 thirds left
and that makes me 3 half to the right.
So to see if I am actually
in the interval 1 to 2,
I make 1 small graphic where I will place 4 thirds
in 1st time,
I place 3 half
and uln is included between these 2
values.
Indeed, 1,
1 iron to 4 thirds
and 3 half-one 1 iron to 2.
So finally
my U N plus 1 is well and truly between 1 and 2.
So I just demonstrated that my cleanliness
is also true
at rank N plus 1.
In conclusion,
I just showed that my property
is true for everything TN.
I will do 2 to 3 exercises,
2 different types
that you may meet during your
senior year.
Subscribe now!